Salut à tous ! Aujourd'hui, toujours et encore une nouvelle énigme.
C'est bientôt la fin de ce petit jeu de l'été où je vous ai donné une énigme par jour pendant 32 jours.
Et avant de vous donner l'énigme d'aujourd'hui, voici la réponse à l'énigme d'hier, la solution.
Si vous n'avez pas vu la vidéo d'hier, regardez la avant puisque là je donne la réponse maintenant !
La réponse est 0,5. Parce que tous les nombres, sauf le 0 bien sûr, quand on le divise par lui-même, ça donne 1.
20 000 divisé par 20 000, ça donne 1.
0,2 divisé par 0,2 ça donne 1.
Pi divisé par Pi, ça donne 1.
Divisé par une personne, ça donne 1.
Donc 0,5 divisé par 0,5 ça double. Ça donne 1.
Et 1 c'est bien le double de 0,5.
Je trouvais ça marrant et ça vous permettra peut-être de faire votre petit malin de temps en temps
avec cette énigme ou avec l'énigme d'aujourd'hui.
Ça fait quelques jours que je ne vous ai pas fait une énigme sous forme story.
Donc pour l'énigme 27... Petite story !
C'est un homme, un businessman qui demande à son veilleur de nuit,
de le réveiller demain matin à 7H, pour prendre son avion.
Le lendemain matin, le veilleur de nuit réveille son patron, mais lui dit:
"Ne prenez pas l'avion, ne partez pas. J'ai fait un rêve cette nuit. J'ai rêvé que l'avion allait s'écraser, il y à un grand danger, ne le prenez pas !"
Il est tellement persuasif, que le businessman l'écoute et ne va pas à l'aéroport, et ne prend pas l'avion.
Et il s'avère que dans la journée, ils apprennent que l'avion s'est effectivement écrasé,
qu'il y a une défaillance technique et que l'avion s'est craché.
Le businessman appelle son veilleur de nuit, le remercie de lui avoir sauvé la vie
et en profite en même temps pour le licencier.
Question: Pourquoi le businessman a licencié son veilleur de nuit ?
Réfléchissez bien à la question.
Je pense que vous pouvez la trouver, vraiment.
D'ailleurs dès que vous l'avez trouvé, ne mettez pas la réponse dans les commentaires.
Il faut que les autres puissent chercher,
mais mettez un pouce en l'air qu'on voit le nombre de personnes qui ont trouvé la bonne réponse.
Je vous laisse encore profiter de ces derniers quelques jours du mois d'août.
On va bientôt reprendre le calendrier normal de la chaîne. Que vous pouvez consulter dans le descriptif.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de partir, puisque le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an.
Rendez-vous demain à 17h !
Ciao !